[Música]
hola de nueva cuenta qué tal si
hubiéramos estado en muchas ocasiones de
repente me encuentro algún conocido o
algún amigo y se refiere a que a esto se
está dedicando en la actualidad una
palabra que de repente pues la función
interpretar de tantas maneras
quizás estamos hablando de alguien pues
que ya inició una empresa la dio de alta
tiene un producto servicio definido es a
procurar cliente es hacer algunas ventas
ya tiene personal y está buscando que
este negocio negocio en serio vaya
creciendo
pero quizás no sea ese el caso quizá
este cuate es un chavo no tan chavo que
tiene una idea entonces alrededor de
esto empieza a pensar en cuáles son los
segmentos de mercado abordar y empieza a
cuestionar cuál es la propuesta de valor
que va a plantear
entonces hace pensar que se da cuenta
que hay alternativas mejores y empieza
pivotear y busca su envite establece su
canvas se acerca a algunas comunidades y
de repente decide que va a dedicar un
fin de semana las 54 horas más valiosas
de su vida para crear está
se encuentra en esta comunidad
potenciales mentores y empieza un
poquito a soñar que va a levantar
capital
y se pone como una meta meterse a un
tanque de futuro
quizá en este amigo es millennial
hipster entonces mientras va
trasladándose en una bicicleta es una
tipa el wey empieza a pensar cuál va a
ser el siguiente post en su blog de que
le va a hablar las unidades seguidores y
de repente se detiene con un child
dice bueno pues vamos a revisar cuántos
likes y cuántos nuevos seguidores tengo
se cuestiona si la ruta es tener un
mercado y lanzarlo o en centrarse en sí
mismo y tratar de posicionarse como un
buen influencer
acabo de decir una serie de términos que
de repente en este movimiento estará
porque hace un movimiento es una
comunidad no nos encontramos como parte
de un nuevo vocabulario
y de repente los escuchamos los
entendemos no los entendemos pero
seguramente en algún momento los usados
puede ser un poquito de historia para
hablarles de mi primer estado tenía yo
15 o 16 años estaba en la prepa en una
época maravillosa en la vida y con un
grupo de conocidos amigos y otros no tan
amigos empezamos a crear un proyecto de
una revista estudiantil bastante exitosa
desplazamos al competidor y lo sacamos
del mercado logramos atraer talento
logramos crear una estructura sea una
estrategia tener tres fuentes de
ingresos producto publicidad y eventos y
éramos super conocidos con este proyecto
que se llamaba prisma el reflejo de los
piñones
se va y se mecen nada
es un proyecto realmente exitoso sin
embargo el concepto start-up a pesar de
que ya muchos estos conceptos los
estamos manejando ni tan siquiera estaba
en nuestro vocabulario ni tan siquiera
estaba en el vocabulario de nadie es más
ni tan siquiera nos considerábamos o nos
denominamos emprendedor
simplemente era nuestro grande
hagamos un poquito más de historia y yo
las con 1975 precisamente estos
conceptos son tan jóvenes como yo más
menos nazco en un entorno de
emprendedores y papás mis dioses esa
foto fue tomada en una farmacia en
aquellos tiempos se llamaban boticas yo
pasaba buen parte de mi tiempo de chavo
en esta óptica sin escuchar palabras
como quincena
efe
yo no sabía qué significaba eso en la
medida que viva en 1976 más o menos días
más días menos de cuando esa foto fue
tomada la revista forbes en un artículo
usa por primera vez el concepto estará
para referirse a estas empresas
dinámicas de sectores tecnológicos están
surgiendo en eeuu pero de una manera
sumamente casual 1984 un libro llamado
la fiebre del valle del silicio le
empieza a dar ya más forma es entonces
estamos hablando de un concepto que
según lo veamos tiene 30 o 40 años de
existir 1984 escuchamos hace unos
momentos y ni seattle
entonces estamos hablando de algo
relativamente con temporal pero 30 o 40
años en los que no nos hemos podido
poner de acuerdo en cuál es la
traducción al español no tenemos al día
de hoy un concepto claro definido
homologado de que es un estar en algunos
casos nos de una empresa que está
empezando que ya existen y está
procurando pues crecer en algunos otros
casos se habla de un emprendimiento en
una etapa inicial es decir está apenas
estructurándose estar stalin
menos halagador algunas publicaciones
hablan de un proyecto de empresa
incipiente entonces realizamos a nuestro
cuate histeria no y pensemos si él va a
decir en español traigo un proyecto
incipiente
la verdad es que tomó entonces el
concepto de uno mismo a los amigos del
mar murray donde dice que un estar el
asilo de cine es un emprendimiento
basado en una hipótesis y esto implica
que es una idea nueva no probada nadie
ha hecho este planteamiento al mercado
antes y entonces tiene una posibilidad
de ser mejor distinto superior a lo que
le antecedía y en ese sentido busca un
crecimiento acelerado
bueno pensemos entonces que es un
concepto plenamente americano no tiene
orígenes europeos asiáticos ningún otro
oliveras en eeuu y nuestros padres
nuestros vecinos de eeuu
un amigo que se llama team team
es dinámico emprendedor de hecho lo es
creo que va corriendo tiene una muy
buena idea y dice let's tornado entonces
tiene esta visión porque él en su
cultura desde chiquito tuvo un stand de
limonada y bueno que compitió y cada vez
que competía en algún deporte le daban
un trofeo y en fin el diseño puedo sacar
esos proyectos a la cndh y buscar algo
que le vamos a llamar ecosistema donde
instituciones inventores y quizá algunos
inversionistas etcétera para llegar ahí
y entonces darle forma a su proyecto se
integra al ecosistema invierte algo de
su tiempo y sin algunos apoyos para
formular un proyecto
y de repente está listo y lo echa a
volar
esa es la historia de un emprendimiento
estará en los eeuu claro el ecosistema
sabe que no todos los emprendimientos de
este tipo van a funcionar pero que
algunos sean exitosos pues paga el resto
de los que no y si tu proyecto no fue
exitoso seguramente la segunda vuelta
con un equipo completamente diferente
podías tener un resultado
regresemos entonces a nuestro
emprendedor todo en mi trayectoria
profesional la oportunidad literalmente
de hablar y digamos compartir alrededor
de ese tema pues desde tijuana hasta la
patagonia literalmente entonces creo que
las condiciones culturales y de contexto
en ese sentido son muy similares para
nosotros en todo latino
en muchas ocasiones emprendemos por
necesidad
no emprendemos porque necesito mantener
a la familia
emprendo porque no he podido conseguir
un empleo no porque no he podido
conseguir un empleo que me guste que es
un tanto el paradigma en otras naciones
emprendo de manera individual no tengo
socios no tengo aliados desarrollo un
proyecto por mi propia fe
emprendo una modalidad de autoempleo es
decir el que genera la lana en la chamba
dentro de este proyecto son
prácticamente exclusivamente yo y eso no
es nada más
pero
pues por el estilo a lo mejor soy texto
diseñador ha jugado dentista y mi
emprendimiento es limitadamente un
proyecto estable
está centrado en zonas en desarrollo
locaciones y propuesta de valor es muy
muy poco diferencial es un producto que
sí para mi región mi colonia mi ciudad
tiene algo de novedad pero realmente no
va a ser competitivo en él
parto con muy poco dinero así como
cuando voltea se te olvidó conectar el
celular ya casi se te acaba la pila esa
es la sensación de un emprendedor
latinoamérica estadísticas
centroamericanas de algunos amigos
indican que el promedio usual es de
menos de mil dólares mucho menos de mil
dólares en muchas ocasiones imagínense
cómo hacer rendir esto varios meses o
diez años para que el negocio levante
tremendamente
muchas veces nunca en la historia estos
emprendimientos reciben inversión estoy
hablando de socios capitalistas y no de
crédito bancario porque no ocurre una
porque no hay una industria del capital
en nuestras nuestras regiones y dos
porque muchas veces los proyectos
simplemente por todo lo anterior no son
atractivos o no están legalmente
técnicamente estructurados para que
alguien pueda
entonces esto insisto ocurre a lo largo
de toda nuestra región
no tenemos héroes tampoco dónde está
nuestro bill gates nuestros tips para
que podamos decir si él pudo y es como
el yo yo pueda
steve jobs latinoamericano esteban
chambas no le fue bien
y gates
guillermo puertas en latinoamérica no le
fue bien me van a marchar pero pasados
fracaso hemos escuchado el día de hoy la
palabra fracaso y nuestro concepto de
fracaso es un concepto digamos de
empleador ya sea cuando alguien fracasa
es que ya se acabó el esto es un
concepto distinto al de las economías
donde el emprendimiento acelerado y
prestará éxito esto realmente tiene
forma porque un fracaso es una
oportunidad de volver a iniciar de
aprender de las lecciones de hacer las
cosas mejor de volver a crecer de volver
a nacer
y finalmente tenemos un gran problema de
confianza que estoy hablando de más
serie de conceptos culturales
desconfiamos de nuestros conocidos para
que sean nuestros socios y preferimos
que sea un proyecto más limitado pero
solo nuestro y desconfiamos de las
instituciones en particular del gobierno
y demás pero lo peor de todo es que es
confiamos a esos en los otros mismos de
nuestra capacidad en ese contexto la no
americano las instituciones el
financiamiento de la tecnología son algo
que apenas estamos construyendo lo
tenemos diferenciadores olores sabores
ingenio que nos dan una ventaja y una
diferenciación esta ingeniería del
ámbito que podemos resolver problemas en
cosas bastante simples con bastante
ingenio es algo que nos caracteriza en
los destinos
revisemos el concepto de frugalidad
frugalidad como una capacidad resolver
con mismo presupuesto mínimos recursos
las situaciones delante de nosotros
pensemos en el concepto de resiliencia
esta insistencia a levantarlos cada vez
que nos caemos y seguir adelante
característico también de nuestras
regiones pensemos que además de calidad
se vale tener calidez este corazoncito
apapacho cariño que lo ponemos a nuestra
atención y trato
pensemos en cómo sacar provecho de la
creatividad
y regreso a los conceptos de formalidad
y lo anterior como generar propuestas
nuevas
consideremos que nuestros
emprendimientos nos deben de inspirar
nos deben generar un motor para seguir
adelante
que le pongamos emoción a lo que hacemos
que hagamos algo que haga latir nuestro
corazón y que volteamos a ver que hay
muchas necesidades en nuestro contexto
latinoamericano que las podemos ver como
oportunidades de negocio
entonces podríamos pensar en construir
conceptos propios
difícil con esas palabras pero en
realidad las palabras no importan lo que
importa es la huella que vamos dejando
pasar por este mundo lo que importa es
que desde nuestro corazón desde nuestra
emoción podamos generar propuestas ideas
que las materializamos que las llevemos
a la práctica con las realidades
[Aplausos]
[Música]